hello from Lord Commander snow at Castle
black
I'm I'm to be the new Meister what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones Season seven
prediction video today I want to talk
about our favorite maester in training
Samwell Tarly in some of the experiments
he will be conducting while he is at the
Citadel at the end of season five Sam
left the Nights Watch to head south to
become their new maester now that Aemon
Targaryen is dead considering there are
only two shortened seasons left we know
Sam is going to be on a crash course of
learning everything that he possibly can
in a very short amount of time and based
off some of the set photos that we have
seen it definitely looks like Sam is
going to be hard at work for the time
that he is there you can see stacks of
books all around him I see his studying
for his first midterm
he even has Gilly reading up on some of
the history and legends of Westeros but
there is another photo that was recently
released that really got my attention
which is the photo of Sam wearing some
sort of lab coat and he's covered in
blood what I love about this photo is we
know for a fact now that Sam is going to
be doing some sort of medical procedures
now we know he didn't go to the Citadel
just to try to help John inserts for
stuff about the long night or how to
make Valyrian steel or how to become a
wizard or stuff like that but if you
look behind him you can also see a scale
with what looks to be a brain or a heart
or something like that laying on it but
it's the look on Sam's face and the
direction he's looking in that really
has me curious this may sound crazy to
some of you but I believe this is when
Sam is going to meet Jorah Mormont for
the first time by the local and Sam's
face it appears that he is looking at
someone that just walked into the room
and since this is a room where medical
procedures are done I think this is when
he meets jour to talk about his
greyscale and how they can cure it or at
least prevent it from spreading any
further and ultimately killing him the
last time we saw Jorah Mormont was
mid-season six when he revealed to
Daenerys Targaryen that he contracted
greyscale on his arm which is when
Daenerys told Jordie go get himself
cured and then come back to her because
she did want him at her side when she
made it to Westeros even though tyrion
suggested otherwise knowing how much
you're loves Daenerys we can be sure
that he will do just that but the only
problem is greyscale is extremely deadly
and very hard to treat but if there is
one place in the world that could
potentially give him any time to help it
would most likely be at the
a report came out months ago that said
jorah mormont was filming in old town
but there weren't any photos to prove it
so I can't confirm that but once and
meets Jorah I do believe he will do
everything in his power to help him
Samwell Tarly already has a history with
the Mormons
Joris father was the Vote Commander of
the Nights Watch while Sam was at Castle
black Lord Commander Mormont actually
saved Sam's life back in season 3
episode 1 when Sam was alone north of
the wall and he came face to face with a
white that was carrying some type of
battle axe and right as Sam was about to
be killed
ghost jumped on the white and took it
down but it didn't stop the white from
still trying to kill Sam but it was the
Lord Commander Mormont who showed up
with a torch and burnt the white to save
Sam from being killed by this damn thing
so when Sam learns that Jorah is a
Mormont and his former Lord commanders
son he will be more than willing to help
him out any way that he can about 7
months ago I actually made a video about
jor getting his greyscale cured and in
that video I went over three different
ways I believe he could do this one of
the ways I thought he could get cured
was by Quaife if you remember Jorah had
several encounters with this mysterious
woman and during one of these encounters
quake was putting these interesting
looking symbols on some man's back she
told Jorah that the man had to sail past
old Valyria and all who traveled close
to the doom must have protection in the
television show that's where Jorah ended
up getting his greyscale and since he
already had this connection with quaithe
I figured she was a good candidate to
help jor protect himself from exploiting
any further and also said in that video
that Sam would be a good choice or
helping Jorah since he was at the
Citadel but it was my last option that I
think may end up happening in my
original prediction video I said that
Jorah Mormont may get the same kind of
treatment that big carrion Greyjoy
received in a book Victarion Greyjoy is
the brother of Balin and Euron Greyjoy
and I believe it was then a feast for
crows when Victarion Greyjoy gets into a
duel and badly injures his hand he
eventually gets help from a red priest
named mokoro who does fix his hand but
it ends up making it all charred and
blackened I had a feeling they could do
something like this with Jorah and once
I took a closer look at the arm sticking
out of the cell door in the season 7
trailer that was exactly what I thought
they ended up doing to him we know that
greyscale does darken like we've seen on
the stone men but the arm sticking out
of the cell door looks black and the
skin is split open and appear
that you can see some red tissue under
there in my opinion that arm looks to be
burnt to a crisp
I definitely think that's jour at the
citadel loft up under quarantine until
his treatment is over and they burn his
arm in some way just like the red
priests did the Victorians hand in the
books it would also be kind of poetic in
a way if Sam was the one to do this Lord
Commander Mormont saved Sam's life by
using fire and now Sam can save Jorah
Mormont life by using fire that would be
pretty damn cool if you ask me
also that article came out a few weeks
ago from the Toronto Sun reporter who
spent several days on the Game of
Thrones set talking to the cast and crew
in that article they said they visited
the set of the Citadel where they saw
tons of prop books and book shelves but
the rest are obviously added in
post-production to make the library look
as big as it did in the season 6 finale
but it was the other thing they saw that
was very interesting while they were on
set they saw some type of cell with a
big sturdy door most likely the same one
we saw on the trailer what the arm
coming out of it now I could be wrong
about all this but when you start the
piece together all the information we've
received and all the photos and promos
it seems to fit together which is Jorah
going to the Citadel to get help with
there's greyscale and since Sam is there
he's a character we are already familiar
with this will give him a big role to
play in the meantime so it makes perfect
sense for Sam to be involved in this
plot line if Jorah in fact goes there
for help but like I said at the
beginning of this video I have a gut
feeling this is Sam meeting Jorah for
the first time in this little lab room
in the most recent photo released by HBO
Jorah Mormont still has a much bigger
role to play in the north and the Wars
to come so I think Jorah will be one of
the few characters to survive throughout
the entire series Jorah was in the very
first episode of the Game of Thrones
series and I believe he will be in the
last episode of the Game of Thrones
series as well but that's just my
opinion so we need Jorah cured and back
into the fold as quickly as possible
it's also going to be very interesting
to see the interaction between Jorah and
Lyanna if you think leona was Harshal
and lord man Julian Glover wait until
you see what she says to Jorah for
disgracing the moor Mons name Leona is
going to rip Jorah a new [ __ ] for
sure and it's going to be hilarious but
you're will be forgiven
but not until he takes one hell of a
lashing from Lady Mormont
comment below and let me know what you
think well Sam and Jorah meet in this
room and discuss some type of treatment
for his
armed and what do you believe they will
do in order to stop the greyscale from
taking over drawers entire body and
driving him mad like the stone men that
we've seen I'd like to get everyone's
thoughts on this thanks for watching the
video I do appreciate you taking a time
out of your day to check it out and a
big thanks to my patreon supporters I'll
see you all down below bye